In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, for June 12th, on which we commemorate, are venerable
and God-bearing Father on Norferios, the Great.
On the 12th of the month we celebrate the memory of our venerable Father on Norferios, the
Egyptian.
Towards the end of the 4th century, St. Puffnutios, who was living in a monastery in Egypt,
was inspired to go into the inner desert, to seek men of God there, and to receive their
blessing.
After walking for four days, his provisions, having run out, he fell exhausted.
But an angel came to revive him and guiding him in the desert for fourteen days, during
which he ate nothing, and brought him before a man of a formidable mean.
He was naked and covered with skin, like an animal, wearing only a loincloth made
from tree bark.
His body was so withered by his kisees that it seemed like a corpse and his snow-white
hair had reached the ground.
He called Puffnutios, who had hidden himself by his name, and having exchanged a holy kiss,
told him the story of his life.
He revealed that he was the son of the King of Persia, and that after his birth, obtained
after long years of prayer, his father had received a revelation in which he was told to baptize
him under the name of a Norferios, and to take him immediately to a monastery in Egypt,
to consecrate him to the service of God.
On the way, a doe fed him, and she continued to give him her milk at the monastery until
he reached the age of three.
In this exemplary community, the child grew up in the fear of God, and the love of all his
commandments.
As he continually heard those who lived the solitary life praised as emulators of the prophet
Elias and Saint John the Baptist, who lived in the desert for God alone, entirely turned
towards the life to come without any human consolation.
He was seized with an insatiable desire to imitate them.
He finally left the monastery by night, and as he was traveling, his guardian angel appeared
to him at the heart of a dazzling light, and promised to give him his help for the rest
of his life.
He guided him to a cave where Hermias, an elderly hermit of Jewish origin, was living.
Hermias instructed him for a few days on the aromatic life, and then took him to his place
of spiritual warfare near a palm tree and a clear spring.
From that time he would visit Onofrios once a year until the time of his blessed death.
And Onofrios there engaged in an unremitting conflict against nature, the weakness of the
flesh and the demons for seventy years.
He endured toward heat, the cold of night and winter, hunger and sickness, in order to obtain
what God has promised to those who love him.
God's aid never failed him, but each time he was in need, he came mightily to his aid.
When his clothes, in rags fell apart, the Lord caused an abundant covering of hair to grow
across the whole of his body, which protected him from the rigors of the climate, and each
day an angel brought him bread.
Bishop of Newtios' question about Holy Communion, the old man replied that each Sunday
God's angel would bring all the solidaries, Holy Communion, which would fill them with
spiritual consolation, and the energy with which to continue their struggles.
Having abandoned every worldly care to commit ourselves to God alone, we do not feel hunger,
thirst, or other afflictions, he said.
And should any of us desire to see men again?
The angels transport him in a vision to paradise, where he sees himself so penetrated with divine
light that he forgets all about his labors and sufferings, and returns to his askeases,
with renewed order.
Nufrius then took his guest to his hut, where they continued their conversation until evening.
Pope Newtios saw the bread that God had sent them, and after fully satisfying their hunger,
they spent the whole night in prayer.
In the morning, O Nufrius revealed to his guest that God had sent him in order to see his
burial, for the time had come for him to go to his celestial dwelling place.
He commanded Pope Newtios to return to live among men, that he might teach them about
the manner of life of the Hermits, and that they might imitate them, each according to
his strength.
After having prayed, he stretched himself on the ground, his face shining with the light
not of this world, and a fragrance filled the air.
Even claps of thunder resounded, and the heavens opened, revealing the whole angelic army,
which had come to receive his soul.
In the midst of this rejoicing, Christ's voice was heard, calling the soul of his servant
to enter into bliss.
Pope Newtios shed many tears over the body of the Holy Ascetic, and was asking himself
how he could possibly dig a tomb in such solid ground, when two lions appeared and dug a pit
for him, in which he was able to place the body.
On the return journey, he met four elders who had been living in a cave for sixty years,
and further on, four other young ascetics, who were living in a paradisical setting.
With noble origin from oxydincos, they had renounced secular studies in order to learn
true wisdom and solitude.
They each lived separately for five days of the week, and came together on Sundays to receive
Holy Communion from an angel.
In spite of his strong desire to remain with them, Pope Newtios was obliged to continue his
journey.
He finally arrived in Egypt, where he witnessed to the truth that men of flesh and blood were
able to live as angels in this world.
He spent the rest of his days in a god-pleasing way and fell asleep in peace, thereby attaining
the dwelling place of the righteous.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.